[Music]
previously on grave hoppers if he dies
at any point for any reason we move on
to Metal Gear Solid 5 I need those three
red [ __ ] regular cores and the best
way to get those is from guardian
walkers I don't think you saw you oh oh
so that's how the yeah well I guess I
wouldn't by the time couple of Bob's
still a decent was oh there's a lot of
them but saw was that wait was that true
fairies no did that second do Drago is
one but that the second dude hit you
with a sword too oh my totally dead
you're right he didn't even let you get
back oh my god you're right urine this
is not good you couldn't hear me I'm
panicking yeah oh my god so sick where
have you been where have you been oh you
need fairies too
you wrote that down little do we know
that would foreshadow what's to come
yeah you know where I should have put it
oh it was first
give me a car course yeah there's one
yeah one more all right but so do you
eat the attack up I'm gonna wait for ya
God you want to start next up so I go
into fatty no then sure hey everyone
welcome back to grave hoppers a show
where we here at GameSpot put permadeath
in every game I'm Mike my Hardy here
with Rob Henry hey hey yeah hi hi
eventful episode last time you got a
bunch of we're about to go get your
stasis for your she could sleep and then
you said you're gonna go get some
durians and then gonna go for the Hylian
Shield maybe Gannon if you get past that
stile knocks yeah in the dungeon they're
not afraid at all I think this is gonna
be it yeah we got we got Metal Gear
Solid for those you knew the show if Rob
survives an hour today or beats Zelda or
no sorry if Rob survives an hour today
we will play Zelda next episode as long
as he doesn't die at all that in Zelda
includes you know fairies can revive you
so we are taking that into account but
if he dies at any point there's no
do-over there's permadeath we were going
to the next game which is Metal Gear
Solid 5 we have ground zeroes loaded up
so I am gonna I'll be playing that I'm
gonna go for Ground Zero before we get
into phantom pain so that's loaded up in
case Rob dies at any point today or if
he happens to beat Ganon before the hour
mark from right now so I'm gonna time an
hour we're good all right
are you know you're not dating already
I'm in hit a no that's where we left off
so yeah let's see if we get this this
stasis I should be able to get bombs
I'll get I'll get plus bombs they call
it the stasis plus same thing I might
meaning I get to drop bombs quicker I
and I think that's the only cost to them
they might do a little more damage if
this is your first episode also you'll
notice that we are at in terms of
permanent health we are only at 3 hearts
we that was one of the rules we made to
not do any shrines in order to build our
stamina or health so if Rob gets again
and he's gonna be fighting him only with
those three permanent hearts and then
whatever other extra hearts he gets from
Niels and been cooking whoops and I have
not I have not done any of the divine
beasts so oh yeah you have to fight all
of Ganon will have a full health bar
hopeful health opposed to half I think
if you include all the divine beast
yeah the laser is just pound him
what's uh were these people's names I
always forget her her I yeah I yeah so
I'll get some durians in Ferren forest
there's a couple more left because we
had a Blood Moon and we went back last
episode and got most of them in that lot
well there's a couple more I could get
in the same lot or just like infer that
he Nyx's and around the area
oh the one you were running away from
the first yeah yeah and then there
should be it dude
I'm like now freakin live from wrong
yeah you're good okay cool
yeah it's East one for those okay Oh see
you okay gotcha
the course only the cores refer the
stasis I didn't realize you were ranking
up everything upgrading everything yeah
should be good right
yeah you're good I think she just had to
but you hadn't asked her about that yeah
I'm game what does this do
this allows you to take photos of items
so you can put them in your compendium
right so you're more so that you're then
able to put them on the the sensor so
you track them okay not really useful
for us in this run but
[Music]
you said the bomb one will let you drop
bombs faster yeah though the cooldown is
shorter Oh gotcha I think it affects the
attack I'm not positive rune goo pick a
berry yeah this is pretty clutch yeah I
mean if you need put during your right
while you're shopping around
I got a few comments on youtube as
always
Frank Romo said I think it's about time
y'all add more challenges or limitations
great series well thank you Frank and
also thank you for suggestion yeah this
episode is kind of gonna be the big big
challenge of Zelda
I think it's do or die today it's going
to be if not this one it's gonna be next
one it's gonna we're gonna yeah I'll
stop I mean I'm going we're going to
highlight this Stalin box yeah a few
Dorian's but yeah we're will be at
hyrule by the end of the episode
Frank Romo thank you for watching and
for suggestion we yes Elvis it don't
look at me tough because it's on master
mode and when you get into fights it's
crazy but it's also like one of those
ones really can be long stretches of not
much going on yeah which is fun when
you're playing by yourself because those
long stretches are like
peaceful or you'll discover something
random or just fun to explore but the
purpose of this show it's not always
that exciting no ni in hindsight I
probably could have we could have picked
a different game we would have
eventually yeah there were some close
calls like last episode how long have
you been surviving six hours before two
hours yeah your half-hour in just so you
know it's getting cool this is the last
one yeah I'm gonna say it is taking a
while it does it can't still give it of
her
so I'll probably go to Ferren forest so
you can get some last-minute durians and
then go to the castle and take over your
shear the stasis will be key that
Allegra's up his eye not even just on
him it'll allow me to like it will give
me a little benefit to like crowd
control I can at least like pause an
enemy if they're like if I have to on me
you know I mean I could like freeze one
and focus on killing another one because
that's it's not just all knocks I'm
afraid of is actually gonna be the
handful it's like three or four silver
maybe gold enemies in the castle that
aren't going to be resisting I think I'm
checking my weapons I think I'm pretty
good on weapons you got a bunch last
time world guard swords and whatnot I
went through a couple
yeah I find that maudlin right or no the
Guardians I lost a couple on the
guardians I think right I got one or two
weapons from them but you got the stasis
oh I think it was worth it
yeah that's it's actually yeah it's
definitely worth it
there's some left here up here yes I
clean this out that noise
that was my attack buff I had on or off
from the Guardians yeah come on you got
some close calls in this series with
climbing only one sigh I didn't make
resisting the urge to jump in it's about
to rain oh god oh god yeah it's never a
comfortable climb are the robos not
metal are they worth want to use head
out this one's okay it isn't okay I
thought for some reason it wasn't when
you just had it out
[Music]
the rain thunder makes your footsteps it
messed your footsteps right yeah
[Music]
clutch at least two more
dragon there don't don't let it tempt
you
I know man I get a horn
no you're just stalling I'm not gonna
let you stall you got you're going up
you're facing your fears today what
would a horn do I'm doing it oh my god
you're just looking for any chance no
I'm not no this is better this is gonna
be this is a potential 30-minute attack
buff all right
worth it big
hey where the [ __ ] to you go the scales
that he dropped oh you just you can only
get one thing at a time
what were those other two things he
dropped I don't know I tire mark
three other motes of two other motes of
light came off him
there's no way I saw three of them like
I promised you I saw three it could have
been this it could have been one like
with like I don't know it just light
effects do I have three bananas
what would you need those for stamina it
would only make it would make the attack
buff to workout
really hate this
what are you trying to do now get skin
more Darien's yeah and maybe bananas
[Music]
you check as you do it on the fourth
yeah that wizzrobe go for those roots
maybe I know it sounds pretty cool
well I might as well just go this
goddamn tower mhm
wait what are you going power flow to
castle I'm on Frank I got Mon I'm on
okay all right all right Frank Romo side
we got to make gotta make a challenging
okay you're just stalling everybody
knows you're afraid
chief coiler frequent reviewer said my
butt clenched so hard me lost those
fairies same with me our butts were all
pretty clenched and I peed a little too
yeah
so for people who might not know the
benefit of the Highland shield is that
it is essentially indestructible right
pretty much yeah and unlike other
shields it won't just like break and
you'll need to block some stuff when
you're fighting again and where the
style knocks want to get three I get
three bananas I'm set for like I get
three bananas I'm set
well how long will it take to find them
sorry cuz you're 15 minutes in okay I'm
really 15 minutes mm-hmm all right yeah
all right it's my job to make you face
your fears that's fair
maybe beetle will sell it to me bananas
yeah sorry I know I asked ready but
bananas will do what three bananas of my
thistle and a dragon horn will give me
30 max attack buff and for 30 minutes
you didn't get a horn though you got a
scale [ __ ] well it'll be a little bit
less
wake up this carrot nose only gives you
light arrows during the second phase of
the boss right of ganon yeah yeah
are you still focus on darienne's sad
with that picking up Oh sick you're not
gonna make that you get you get a meals
all right fine yeah let's do it [ __ ]
I'll cook that mixture and this will
still be decent you said with a without
the horn this will be a last minute
health that's that's a good piece of
health there and then a ferry and then
I'll do this dragon scale that's like
the whole fight the question is do you
use that on the stale box no I'll try
not to
okay my gonna [ __ ] Rico let's see if
there's at least one worth a
okay if it's not that's it's clear it's
fair to see if there are fairies yeah
absolutely
but I haven't won over that one fair
after that we're out
yeah and I'll check Euler fountain to
know then that's it no me and frankerd
are telling you not checking two
fountains you're taking one fountain I'm
making an executive decision as the
current host you can make these
decisions when I play metal gear it's my
own fault that I haven't gotten this far
in a game I guess well actually no
that's not sure it was Mary I've done it
with resin needle yeah I could have done
I would doom but I really screwed up I
bet that hurt I'm Way more than resin
evil did doom because went for our pilot
I had gotten an hour and a half through
or something yeah okay so I'm gonna try
this trick that people were saying on I
want to make sure I know the right okay
wait are you gonna lose that fairy I'm
trying not to okay well there's a track
others worked oh [ __ ] nice that's useful
now
is there a limit how many times you do
that yeah ice actually he they said if
you get to then
- does what I don't know Wow my heart is
racing just holding those alright yes
coming for you stale knocks alright so
the best way to go I'm gonna actually
have to go on horse cuz it's just gonna
be easier could you just leave the
castle and loop around yeah but it just
puts me in a weird spot I don't know I
could go here anyways no that's up to
you you're playing we're going on horse
get you to the entrance near the shield
faster is that what you're saying
kind of yeah not just do it I'm not
stalling hockey w I'm saying that
correctly said this series is awesome
it's a net gain as Mike would have put
it it's a good selection of games but
any thoughts about some older games like
oh I don't know Bucky O'Hare for the NES
it's an out-there suggestion I know just
thinking outside the box
um older we've I think the farthest back
we've got so far is like 360 games just
for the ease of we have to consider like
switching between them so right now
we're still we're a lien isolation is
ready to go in PC if I were to die in
metal gear but we could yeah there's
nothing like preventing us from
streaming in terms of nes that might be
tough because I know I don't I'd have to
ask like Eric kr resident tech expert
like how to stream those games I'm sure
you would know how I just in terms of
older games we're sticking into newer
ones are now just cuz they're easier to
stream and switch between
obviously for the show that the
switching is a big part but yeah
ya know there's no like there's no out
of the question game at all
but in terms of like the games we pick
it's pretty much always like like for a
while I was thinking maybe shadow of
Mordor then I was like no cuz that game
is better when you die and come back and
having a nemesis and stuff so as a guy
that wouldn't work as well games that
you really don't want to die in are a
little better I might win I might use
one of these I just made like a
four-minute one
I might use that what was it attacked
triple to max attack buff for four
minutes five minutes okay she's pretty
good but saw and I could save the other
one for gain and giving my
Oh actually when this publishes I will
have been able to say that we saw a
little bit of red dead redemption - yeah
and I kept just thinking of but stall
every time I saw a horse in that game
yeah it was a bird is the punch noise
it's like such a cup comedic oh yeah
like a Bugs Bunny slap yeah that
Guardian music this music yeah this is
the horseback music that eventually can
turn into the O's all the song it's like
a slowed down version of classic maybe
we'll hear if I don't get into a fight
you have two fairies pretty good in food
weapons are good I'm looking better than
I you good I'm looking better than I
thought
yeah shields I'll be good for sure bows
you got a few decent options yeah this
might be suicide isn't it the way you
came last time
I'm coughing Jesus God let's talk but
stall it yet again you've screwed us I
love my horse what can I say I love my
horse his his stupidity has screwed us
once again oh you know we can go get is
that another roll remember that remember
his buddy was right there I don't know
no I thought there's a flying guardian
wait a second there's no chest there now
this is a different one yeah maybe I
might just maybe the draw distant I mean
I know that's not far but maybe it would
be all it was on that platform and he's
right it's not there I don't know maybe
sometimes the draw distance in this game
is if he oh wait is over there no I was
around the I don't know that's where you
want to go right yeah that's weird all
right
like I don't know maybe those platforms
are random maybe that's like those are
only master mode yeah maybe that's a
characteristic that we might never
really investigated that
Jesus
when how we'll note yeah
like he's gonna toss it in the water you
don't get any good weapon you get a
torch
I always thought these guys took more
than just a bomb well they're like
little the little children of the bigger
star yeah
nice dolls don't think so no salsa's
bone they're called tau calluses
[Music]
all right getting closer I told you
right that I thought yeah yeah I mean I
guess it saves weapons to not do what I
was doing
so terrified of doing it so close Adam
to blow myself up
we're cruising and here we go pick up a
couple hard-boiled eggs
no that's bullcrap
they're hard boil eggs and they're
usually yeah that's how you cook one or
normally yeah
[Music]
got your like 30 minutes in 30 minutes
okay here we go
[Music]
perfect
you
[Music]
mm tonight I think about it some of
these guys don't have to
did you try to spit you probably could
oh they're all out I was wrong oh my god
yeah I brought a friend called spacious
you little punk-ass [ __ ] my friend Stan
I see white yeah white ones a silver
yeah
well that's gonna break right now oh you
[ __ ] that up fighting guardian legs
wow that was quick crap all right one
down do you have to fight them not
necessarily I mean I could bypass him I
thought he's this way oh yeah that's all
boy you're right I could get past him
okay well let's go do the style next way
I see that way are you doing the Ganon
theme song I'm just getting that's not
the Ganon theme song it's such a good
song look at all the bones of its
previous enemies
let's dance yeah put your dumb head on
oh oh I see so oh you got this you're
fine
oh yeah my torch good start
Oh my torch yes and that's a good opener
you could do it with just with your
arrows and he is really weak uh here I
feel like an idiot I mean it's still the
door locks that's the scary part yeah oh
that was a little too close okay I see I
see what you mean now like that allows
you to shoot I know because if I now
when he gets half he would have been
covering it correct do you think it's
smart to even be using a melee weapon on
him with the limited number you have
because you're doing like this much
damage zone with each arrow
you think I should use arrows well each
time you hit his eye with an arrow it's
doing like pretty good deal of damage oh
yeah so this parts a little can it's a
little confusing but like I oh yes hell
yeah his eye now retains his health
clicking more fun nice that's it let's
go drew Gannon I guess I'm just that
good yeah let's go dig in all right oh
that's a huge upgrade I'm gonna pick up
Oh God we're really doing Gannon oh I'm
gonna pick like it's thumb nice Oh God
we're doing Gannon yeah yeah we are I'm
gonna pick up those three ancient arrows
are they close by let's do ban in this
episode though the watch was gonna have
an inventory phone system hmm
did I hear student mind by I mean it's
clutching thunderstorms but this is a
little better
SiC do you have to go far for those
ancient arrows um I'm trying think where
they are they are there outside so I
need to go remember I got to go 200
nemesis yeah I remember that I just
didn't I get to him I'll just I'll find
my way out and see how it goes
my just Brent [ __ ] let's do Ganon
this episode though yeah oh great this
guy's coming out oh you rock walking to
the sconce on the wall and he did
himself I got the sconce what's the term
for a wall torch crazier crazier crazier
razor
ouch later well the good news is I also
have a tack up not having used all right
no need
[Music]
she looks good on you look at this
dumbass Matt I need okay so it's there
oh I need to go just to the right and
keep hugging around maybe I can climb up
a little bit
have you what's the earliest you've ever
have you fought Ganon without doing
divine beast before no have it its ear
BOCES fury or whatever it's called that
really makes it easy you'd be that dome
of electricity and then that's what
stuns him when he's got his shields up
[Music]
pretty close
as per use
I said it's worth it for time
oh it feels a whole call oh so that
quarter is extra yeah so I'm actually
I'm in the clear [ __ ] Tony Hawk over
here Oh almost gotcha
cool I thought I could hide lychee
others would scare him
oh I was wrong that was done I went
almost I didn't all this made the worst
mistake I think this is it all right
[Music]
sure
yeah yeah water here and then down at
the end yeah we all know this place can
you sprint by this little Alfa I could
freeze him
oh right does he have a name yet the
Nemesis name is but mantra but style bug
muncher if you were to wait till I turn
around then freedom and that make more
sense this guy needs to die horrible
horrible Perry dude Ganon's gonna be a
piece of cake after this dude I'm just
gonna wait for my team
Oh stasis
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I'm giving you all the elements cuz
I hate you that much
I wonder if stasis would work on this
well that he's still got like eight
parts out of you you gotta go to meal so
these are good for Gannon no
[Music]
this is where they just didn't respond
why for the Blood Moon
why wouldn't they not respond that's
messed up
[Music]
it's my weapon selection on it right
here
[Music]
well
[Music]
this should hopefully for me you know
better
an area that might have some Royal Guard
weapons I use my
[Music]
Wow
now let's just go from
[Music]
my right
no pairing today
[Music]
that you're gonna try again I keep
wanting to
idiot
Oh No
good thing I didn't drop down there why
it's over Lionel spawns
am I supposed to get
yes I do have a developer and then to
the right okay
[Music]
I guess other people dissolve this room
there's actually a should be good weapon
in there
I'm gonna break one screw it Oh
it's go outside first right and then up
I want to mean to do that
this time I wanted good God idea
I lost all my fairies I'm just doing
this because I'm pissed off damn it
that royal
[Music]
yeah but stall
that's why Nina
well Ganon's gonna be harder yeah now
whatever just making to be more cautious
that's how it works
[Music]
I'm really glad to climb the tower over
there
[Music]
he chases those
it's happening
I have faith in you
it's exciting
shits about to go down
[Music]
the last photo of link it's probably eat
something right
yeah the Royal that's what we're all
right well yeah all right I wanna think
one second so I'll probably go
I lost two fairies
I wait for the attack
I mean shy open with this might as well
if you get hit at all
you have no fairies start off on
confidence feel good
all right
come what may this is the last episode
of Zelda I think you could do it all
these guys in the beginning yeah for God
I'm screwed
[Music]
you got you have a lot of health and
stasis
good to know
[Music]
wait so if you don't do the divine
beasts who fight these guys first yeah
oh I didn't know that
that did nothing
you're messing about
[Music]
[Music]
or she went away
charging
as annoying
nice and to link
Oh
[Music]
yeah oh [ __ ] him up
[Music]
do it
you think are so slow
stop doing that
yeah do something faster
[Music]
yes yes yeah one down all right
[Music]
that's a freebie dude can you even
perfect dodge this dude
what yeah I can try
do it again you goddamn
nice
Jesus
oh there you go
gum has a halfway point doing good
I mean you kind of don't because you
kill him a different area yeah he does
this that's right he's not just backing
him right
[Music]
[Music]
yeah oh oh yeah yeah yeah that works
oh no that's such crap
I am running out of arrows so quickly
well I mean this place oh I mean I'm not
gonna do it from there
much better thank you
Oh
[Music]
we can get them no matter what
Oh
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so you
bounce off do that such crap
I hate you a lot
wait jump up yeah jump through the
mid-air shot let you shoot him few times
here we go and just why don't you jump
and shoot him with arrows I think
there's some stuff above us
yeah nice oh my I forgot
oh no attacks no stung toys forgot about
that
oh yeah yeah
oh yeah you go
dick
[Music]
god
I like run and do it no I I don't think
so
Jesus Christ
yeah you got this one there's two down
you know what the last one is no it's a
thunder bright thunder fight right
excuse me thunder light he's the extreme
earth fire boys not bad right how's that
feel thank God for the shield oh I
didn't have my shield
yeah oh you got this one no problem give
you perfect dodge thrown in there no
problem no problem
that's a little cheap oh that stuns him
fine shake it off you got him
yeah I just [ __ ] spam those bombs
save you arrows everything yeah there
you go two-and-a-half divine these down
time some person perfect dodges is that
how it goes and what couldn't tell you
Mike
Oh
Oh easy-peasy this one's not gonna be
hard
hey I hope you like yeah do that [ __ ]
again I love it when you do that do it
again
yeah yeah yeah you got him cancel that
yes
welcome to the Thunderdome you doing
good just don't get hit I don't remember
this one well shield - this is more
about dotting right
[Music]
very valiant effort got through three of
the bosses of the five technically that
was good
whoa oh I see what you mean about the
thunder blight yeah he's kind of a dick
could you have stasis dead I don't know
what you would have done like the shield
was preventing you from I don't know I
kind of panic dude I'd like I just
forget how to handle that guy in general
he's so tough well that was that was
good
you got you got far farther than I would
have with no trying to pretty far a guy
I got far all right well do you wanna
want to pull up the list then we'll
start metal gear next time so that
should be like today today was like
seven hours in the 45 minutes you
survived me we go over an hour yeah yeah
about like 20 minutes
I know ten minutes so yeah like a seven
and half hours Metal Gear Solid next as
always everybody thank you for joining
grave hoppers we are moving on to the
next game that's the rules it was a good
episode no matter what I enjoyed it
Rob might be feeling this one for a bit
there's nothing to be ashamed of that
was that was good
even if I had even if I had fairies I
still have been messed up because well
because of how many hearts so every time
I would take a hit I'm already dead you
know what I mean like at some point it
doesn't matter if I have fairies and the
respect that like yeah it's two hits but
you get I'm saying I would I needed more
temporary hearts of anything like those
wood fairy yeah fairies and temporary
hearts go hand-in-hand so either way
either right yeah nice job and everybody
thank you for joining us this is a great
hoppers goes up every Thursday on
GameSpot calm and YouTube we will see
you next week with Metal Gear Solid 5
Ground zeroes and eventually phantom
pain hopefully if I survive ground
zeroes on hard see you then
how do we do it stupid outro